With all the under the hood stuff out of the way,
let's talk about scripting and blueprint.
Blueprint is an extensive suite of tools
built on top of a C++ foundation,
allowing developers to start creating immediately.
It's built directly into the editor
and pairing any member of the team,
be they design, art, or anything in between,
to start developing their ideas
with a significantly reduced iteration time,
making it ideal for testing out ideas,
making it great for prototyping.
But, well-structured blueprint can and should
be considered production code,
and mechanics built in blueprint shouldn't be dismissed
because they're not in native C++.
Traditional concepts that apply to programming
also apply here, as blueprint is,
for all intents and purposes,
a fully featured, fully functional,
and feature-rich programming environment
and should be treated as such.
When developing in blueprint,
it's important to consider factors
that you would otherwise consider in regular code.
Is this going to kill my frame rate?
Is this math function as efficient as it could be?
Have I built my blueprint in an object-orientated manner?
With that in mind,
where does that leave the traditional engineer
when it comes to such a powerful scripting engine?
There's a whole spectrum of tools
that we can develop as engineers
to give our designers and artists,
as well as ourselves,
more fleshed out tools when working in the raw C++.
Ultimately, blueprint sits on top of the project's code,
so we can expose our areas of the code
to give the team more gadgets to play with.
Exposing at functionality is staggeringly easy
when using Unreal's reflection system,
specifically the U function and U property specifiers
and their associated meta.
As an expansion of the U function specifiers,
we've got the blueprint callable.
So imagine we've got a complex set
of mathematical functions that really do benefit
from being in C++.
We can define the complex function in code
and have our blueprint layer call it.
The blueprint callable with a const keyword
or blueprint pure
gives us a single getter node in blueprint.
Typically, most blueprint nodes need to be executed,
marking a function as const
or indeed having it marked as a blueprint pure meta,
will give us a node that simply pulls the value
without executing anything at all.
Blueprint implementable event is a function
that we can call from code,
but execute it on the blueprint itself.
So say we've got some cosmetic functionality
that we want to trigger from code,
but we don't have access to the required assets
or components to manage that effect in the code.
It's not a problem,
we can create a blueprint implementable event
and hook up our cosmetics on the blueprint graph.
A blueprint native event is very similar
to a blueprint implementable event,
but it also has a native implementation.
If this function isn't overridden on the blueprint graph,
the native implementation will be called instead.
Moving on to you property, we have UI min and UI max.
This provides a slider in editor for the user
to enter a float value clamped at the entered values.
It does not prevent the user from entering a value
outside of the desired bounds however.
For that, we need to look to clamp min and clamp max,
which will cause the values entered into a float parameter
to be bound with this range.
From there, we can look at display name.
This changes what name is displayed
besides this parameter in the editor.
And it's useful for when we want
a very descriptive naming code,
but maybe a more succinct contextual one in the editor.
From there, we have blueprint getter and blueprint setter.
This allows us to manually define a function to call
when directly getting and setting a member variable.
It's useful if we want to call another piece of code
directly whenever a value changes in blueprint.
As mentioned, blueprint is a fully featured language
and as such supports interfaces.
Interfaces can be defined in C++
and implemented in blueprint
with any of its virtual functions
free to implement the U function markup.
In order to achieve this expansion though,
we must mark up our interface
with the U interface blueprintable specifier.
When calling an interface function
on a blueprint class from native,
we first have to check the object that we're working with
actually implements this interface at all.
Alternatively, you could cast the object
to the intended interface.
That too would let us know if it implements it.
If it does, we can go ahead and call the function
using a statically generated execute function
following the above syntax.
The parameters being the object
we wish to call the function on,
followed by any parameters that are required
for that function signature.
Unreal's architecture has an incredible degree
of flexibility and helps put power
into designers and artists hands
when getting their ideas out and working in the project
and to a production level.
The idea that blueprint is for non-programmers
or for prototyping is demonstrably incorrect
and the two methods of development,
that being traditional engineering and blueprint
should be seen as working hand in hand,
not in opposition to each other.